jetzt schauen wir hier in dieser sendung
auf den wohl bekanntesten und auch
streitbarsten diplomaten in deutschland
viele menschen vor allem politiker
aufgeregt mit seinen oft provokanten und
auch direkten tönen und jetzt soll
schluss sein für manic bild erfuhr jetzt
an remake wird deutschland verlassen und
nach kiew zurück gehen ja unser
gekämpft für sein land und ist dabei
fielen auf den schlips getreten andré
melnik der ukrainische botschafter ist
der wohl bekannteste und gleichzeitig
umstrittenste diplomat in deutschland
und meine frage an sie was würden sie
opfern würden sie ihre
opfern oder oder brandenburg oder oder
sagst es eine spaßige opfern
jetzt diese nachricht bild erfuhr
exklusiv melnik wird deutschland
verlassen und nach kiew zurück gehen er
wird seinen botschafter job in berlin an
den nagel hängen und zurück in die
heimat gehen dort soll er
stellvertretender außenminister der
ukraine werden zuletzt war wenig für
seine äußerungen über den ukrainischen
nationalisten führer stepan bandera
scharf kritisiert worden an der wird in
teilen der ukraine als nationalheld
verehrt soll aber auch an massakern an
juden im zweiten weltkrieg beteiligt
gewesen sein er hat israel unrecht
israel der staat israel wir haben
hunderttausende auch von der asta sowie
israel dass sich das aus ich weiß nicht
was nicht aussehen aber wir reden über
bande ja und wir reden immer wieder
ganze welt erkennt an dass bandera an
nein das stimmt zwar dass es gibt keine
es gibt keine belege dass das bundle
truppen hunderttausende juden ermordet
es gibt keinen beleg
keine frage er ist ein streitbarer
diplomat der sich nicht davor scheut
sich mit den mächtigsten anzulegen nicht
erst seit beginn des ukraine krieges
schon seit 2014 seit der annexion der
krim haute andré melnik kräftig auf den
putz kritisierte merkel steinmeier und
stolz auf später bezeichnete melnik
bundeskanzler olaf scholz als beleidigte
leberwurst
seine wortwahl nicht immer diplomatisch
dafür ehrlich und direkt und oft
provokant jetzt wird es leiser und
vielleicht bequemer für einige
und wir sind jetzt verbunden mit unserem
bild reporter bild vize paul ronzheimer
der in der ukraine ist in kiew und dort
für uns berichtet paul wenig war nie
unumstritten was glaubst du ist jetzt
die begründung für seine versetzung
es gibt verschiedene gründe dafür zum
einen ist magic bereits seit fast acht
jahren in deutschland das ist höchst
ungewöhnlich normalerweise ist ein
diplomat in botschafter vier bis sechs
jahre maximal dort also ist hätte
tatsächlich turnusmäßig auch eine
veränderung geben müssen demnächst aber
dann kommen natürlich die debatte um ihn
und da gibt es unterschiedliche
meinungen die einen haben das
unterstützt was er zu waffen gesagt hat
insbesondere am anfang die anderen
fanden auch in der ukraine die rhetorik
möglicherweise etwas zu scharf und an
der dritte punkt die aktuellen
diskussionen um bandera also dass er
sich hinter den ehemaligen
nationalistenführer gestellt hat und
eben nicht ja die historischen
ereignisse so bewertet hat dass lehrer
eben für den mord an juden
mitverantwortlich oder verantwortlich
war und das hat dann für heftige
kontroversen gesorgt unter anderem in
polen in deutschland aber auch hier in
der ukraine also ist es wohl ein mich
aus allem ein bisschen gleichzeitig das
was ich höre es geht hier nicht um eine
degradierung wenig sondern wenn es so
kommen sollte dass es zumindest im
gespräch dann würde er stellvertretender
außenminister werden diesen vorschlag
gibt es möglich ist dass der präsident
diesen ablehnen beziehungsweise ist noch
andere vorschläge gibt aber sollte es so
kommen
dann kann man jetzt nicht von einer
degradierung sprechen dann wäre das
sogar eine beförderung
also das verhalten wir weiter im auge
und paul du hast mit jemanden gesprochen
sozusagen aus dem inner circle
präsidenten flüsterer haben wir ihn
genannt mikado podolczak wir wollen
einmal in dieses interview reingehen und
es geht es startet mit der frage wie die
deutschen intellektuellen die jetzt auch
wieder ein brief verfasst haben dort in
der ukraine aufgenommen werden lasst uns
gemeinsam reinschauen
leider verstehen die deutschen
intellektuellen die natur dieses krieges
nicht ganz es ist kein krieg um ein
stück land oder um irgendeine art von
ressourcen oder um eine
wiedervereinigung dieser republiken die
von der russischen föderation diskutiert
werden
dieser krieg ist für das recht der
russischen föderation ihre bedingungen
und regeln durchzusetzen wenn wir also
diesen krieg falsch beenden wie zum
beispiel beginnen zu verhandeln und
akzeptieren ihre forderung oder einige
ihrer forderung dann werden wir einen
verzögerten krieg haben also einen krieg
der wiederkommen wird
wenn wir uns die situation heute ansehen
können wir sehen dass russland
erfolgreich territorien gewinnt und dass
es mehr waffen und mehr munition hat was
passiert also wenn es monate oder sogar
ein jahr so weitergeht
[Musik]
krieg ist krieg und hat seine regeln
heute kannst du einige gebiete
dominieren und übernehmen morgen kannst
du den krieg verlieren bei einem
modernen krieg geht es um die menge an
ressourcen und die menge an opfern die
sie bereit sind zu verlieren leider hat
sich herausgestellt so dass die
russische föderation bereit ist eine
große zahl ihrer bürger zu opfern
wir mussten uns an einen solchen kriegs
rhythmus anpassen
wir haben eine der deutschen haubitzen
im osten gesehen es gibt nur zwölf was
wollen sie mehr von deutschland was sind
ihre dringendsten bedürfnisse
für uns ist es sehr wichtig dass die
bundesregierung und die öffentlichkeit
ihre außenpolitischen prioritäten
geändert haben jetzt verstehen sie dass
russland kein partnerland sondern ein
gegner land ist und das verständnis für
die deutsche gesellschaft schwer war es
dort und sanieren
was wie viele und wie dringend benötigen
sie waffen aus deutschland
[Musik]
alle langstreckenwaffen langstrecken
haubitzen luftabwehrsysteme wir
benötigen sie in allen verfügbaren
mengen wir verstehen dass die
europäischen länder im gegensatz zu
russland keine großen mengen an waffen
angehäuft haben die europäer investieren
in das leben und den komfort der
menschen wir verstehen dass deutschland
uns geben wird was es gehen kann wir
würden uns freuen wenn wir es etwas
schneller haben könnten um unsere
verluste zu minimieren
das exklusive interview mit dem berater
von us-präsident zellen skipper uns aber
weiterhin dabei uns ja dort wird ja
irgendwie ein gespaltenes bild von
deutschland gezeichnet auf der einen
seite ist man froh darüber dass
deutschland die meinung über russland
endlich geändert hat endlich erkannt hat
wird dort gesagt auf der anderen seite
doch auch enttäuschung heraus zu hören
dass die waffenlieferungen noch immer
nicht in dem ausmaß stattfinden wie sie
gebraucht werden wollen
ja patricia ich sehe aber dennoch oder
höhere eine veränderung der rhetorik die
ist ganz klar also das was jetzt gesagt
hatte man muss dazu sagen er ist
wirklich einer der engsten berater von
seelands dieser wahlen sowie videos von
beginn des krieges dabei schläft dort im
bunker wo auch der präsident schlägt
jeden tag weiterhin
dass er deutschland nicht mehr offen
kritisiert sondern auch lobende worte
findet unter anderem für kanzler oder
scholz und die bundesregierung das zeigt
schon dass man jetzt nicht mehr komplett
drauf hauen will aber und da hast du
vollkommen recht man sagt wir brauchen
mehr also gerade was dieses thema angeht
denn diese frontlinie die ist was 2000
kilometer lang und zwölf haubitzen da
kann man sich vorstellen auch wie wenig
sich das verteilt natürlich tiefer noch
andere aber man hofft in der ukraine
dass deutschland jetzt nachlegt und
weiter liefert denn ansonsten das ist
zumindest mein eindruck den ich dort im
osten gewonnen habe gewinnt russland
zwar langsam aber stetig auch ein thema
das sie ja besprochen heißt in diesem
interview die militärische lage jetzt
gerade im land gestern haben wir
präsident selensky gehört der ganz klar
gesagt hat das ziel ist es den gesamten
donnerstag zu bekommen gleichzeitig
sehen wie er gibt es viele gebiete in
der in russland die kontrolle übernimmt
wie bewertest du diese situation im
moment
das ist schon ein gewisses
ablenkungsmanöver des präsidenten in
diesen nächtlichen ansprache denn er
ging nicht darauf ein dass die ukraine
dort momentan verliert er will sozusagen
die motivation hoch halten er will die
truppen dort motivieren dem osten aber
auch im gesamten land den eindruck
erwecken dass man all diese gebiete
zurückerobern kann patricia das sehe ich
momentan nicht dass man den don was
zurückerobern kann es ist so dass man
den fortschritt der russen verlangsamen
aber nicht aufhalten kann geschweige
denn dass man gebiete zurückerobert
weil hinter dir wir sehen es oft wenn
wir mit ihr sprechen und danach ist es
so wahnsinnig eindrucksvoll diese
sandsäcke die sich hinter dir stapeln um
damit auch das stück geschichte die
denkmäler in der hauptstadt in der
kriegs hauptstädte zu schützen schilder
uns einmal diesen kriegsalltag in der
hauptstadt
in kiew ist normalität eigentlich so gut
wie normalität wieder eingekehrt zwar
sind noch diese denkmäler hier hinter
mir geschützt da geht es aber auch darum
zeichen zu setzen und plakate
aufzuhängen und zu sagen dass die welt
die ukraine weiter unterstützen müsse
hier versucht in einen normalzustand zu
kommen aber natürlich weiß man auch hier
dass jederzeit wieder raketen
einschlagen können wir ändern uns und
das was vor zwei wochen drei wochen
passiert ist hier in kiew und es ist ein
bisschen abwarten man schaut etwas
nervös richtung belarus was wäre wenn
von dort soldaten kämen würde das
bedeuten hier würde wieder angegriffen
und keiner glaubt hier daran dass kiew
einfach so verschont bleibt also wenn
russland sozusagen im osten weiter
vorankommt dann möglicherweise richtung
odessa oder schief gehen könnte alle
wissen das ist eine frage der zeit dann
wäre das war diese putin auch wieder
kiew angreift
132 tage krieg mittlerweile paul du
bleibst für uns in der ukraine und
bericht ist weiterhin jeden tag live von
dort vielen dank erstmal für heute für
deine eindrücke